[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour la France a toujours été notre
alli elle n'a jamais été notre
adversaire elle sera toujours notre amie
ces mots sont ceux du président Nixon
qui à l'issue du dîner offert hier soir
à la Maison Blanche apportter ce toast
en l'honneur du président de la
République française voilà qui résume le
ton de cette première journée puisque le
premier tête à tête Nixon Pompidou a été
de la vie même du président de la
République cordial constructif et
réaliste sachez aussi que le président
Pompidou a franchi avec succès le cap
difficile du face à la presse américaine
sachez que Madame Pompidou de laaveu de
la presse américaine ambassadrice du
charme féminin français a connu un grand
succès son maxi mentau notamment a
beaucoup étonné allant jusqu'à
surprendre monsieur Pompidou lui-même
qui ne savait pas que le manteau de son
épouse avait rallongé de 20 cm au cours
des deux derniers mois sachez enfin que
l'on a dîné à la française hier soir à
la Maison Blanche saumon lafillette
contrefilet de bœuf aux cepes et aux
asperges laitu du kentuki fromage de
camamber melon glacé à la vigronne avec
des raisins de Californie vin de France
et de Californie mais George George
pitolev quel était le menu pour
aujourd'hui pour aujourd'hui menu assez
chargé il est actuellement 7h du matin à
Washington une longue journée attend le
président de la République dans 2h
environ petit- dééjeuner de travail avec
Monsieur Melvin lerd ministre de la
Défense puis rencontre avec David
Kennedy ministre des Finances euh à ce
propos il ne fait pas partie de la
famille du président Kennedy puis à 12h
dei monsieur Pompidou prononcera un
discours devant les parlementaires des
deux Chambres réunies en séance commune
au Capitol il est possible d'ailleurs à
ce sujet qu'un certain nombre de
parlementaires américains boycottent
cette séance pour manifester leur
mauvaise humeur voir leur hostilité à la
politique française à l'égard d'Israël
et des pays arabes dans l'après-midi
nouveaux entretiens politiques également
avec Monsieur William Rogers secrétaire
d'État c'est-à-dire ministre des
Affaires étrangères après avoir reçu cet
après-midi les dirigeants des deux
grands partis américains républicains et
démocrates le président de la République
offrira ce soir à l'ambassade de France
un dîner de gala en l'honneur du
président Nixon et on a abondamment
souligné le fait que c'était la première
fois que le président Nixon acceptait de
se rendre à une réception offerte dans
une ambassade à Washington mais je crois
que l'on peut dire George pitev que dès
hier le président Pompidou a fait des
déclaration importante notamment pendant
sa conférence au National Press Club le
quartier général de la presse américaine
à Washington oui et premier point les
journalistes américains qui pourtant
sont réputés avoir la dent dure ont
donné leur satisfacite au président
Pompidou sur Israël et les pays arabes
question attendue entre toutes monsieur
Pompidou a déclaré la capitale de la
France n'est pas le CER je dois dire que
ce n'est pas non plus tel à vivre dans
cette affaire nous cherchons la paix
dans notre intérêt dans la l'intérêt de
la situation en Méditerranée et dans
l'intérêt de la paix en général rien ne
serait plus grave dit-il que de
transformer le conflit entre Israël et
le monde arabe en un conflit entre l'Est
et l'Ouest le président réaffirme avec
vigueur que le gouvernement français est
pour l'existence et la sécurité de
l'État d'Israël il précise ensuite
l'État d'Israël ne doit pas être une
espèce de tête de pont dans le monde
arabe mais il doit s'insérer dans
l'ensemble du Moyen-Orient où Arabes
israéliens juifs et chrétiens et
musulmans acceptte de vivre ensemble le
président de la République répète alors
que dans les circonstances présentes
l'organisation des Nations Unis et en
particulier les quatre grands
c'est-à-dire les quatre membres
permanents du Conseil de sécurité
doivent se mettre d'accord pour définir
les conditions d'une solution à la crise
actuelle solution devant avoir bien
entendu l'aval des partis intéressées
oui mais ce ne sont pas là les seules
formules ayant frapper l'imagination des
Américains il y en a une autre par
exemple que je lis maintenant à propos
de la Libye il y avait un vide nous
l'avons comblé c'était notre intérêt et
l'intérêt de bien d'autres et d'autres
formules comme celle-ci la France est un
allié de libre choix et non pas un allié
d'obligation ou encore à propos des
investissements américains en France
Monsieur Pompidou déclarait ils sont les
bienvenus s'ils apportent une richesse
réelle et non s'ils se traduisent par
une simple prise de contrôle à bon
compte des sociétés françaises en ce qui
concerne l'accueil du président français
je crois que dans la rue il y a eu
quelques manifestations qui sont
traduites par une vingtaine
d'arrestations
en effet et dans la salle même une jeune
fille israélite de 18 ans a poussé des
cris hosyes du genre Pompidou assassin
mais très rapidement elle a été
maîtrisée et puis dans la soirée on
s'est retrouvé pour un dîner de gala il
y avait 102 conviv
oui en effet dîner offert à la Maison
Blanche cette fois-ci par Monsieur Nixon
et Madame Nixon en l'honneur du
président de la République et de Madame
Pompidou les deux chefs d'État et leurs
épouses se sont surpassés diton on parle
déjà d'une soirée de gala éblouissante
il n'est question que de la amitié
profonde bien parfois difficile unissant
la France et les États-Unis depuis deux
siècles il y a des querelles mais ce
sont des querelles de familles les deux
chefs d'État ont répété chacun à sa
manière que l'amitié franco-américaine
était inébranlable un seul point
litigieux dans ce dîner de gala où le
sommelier servait des vin français les
vignerons de Californie ont protesté
parce qu'on avait pas tenu compte de
leur grève et qu'on avait décoré la
table avec des raisins de Californie
merci George pitf il nous faut revenir
en France et en Europe où le mauvais
temps continue d'inquiéter de N
nombreuses régions et tout d'abord les
Alpes où les risques d'avalanche sont
accrus au cours des derniers jours ce
matin dans plusieurs régions des Alpes
suisse et française on dresse des bilans
13 morts 17 disparus 18 blessés à
rekingen en Suisse 66 écoliers bloqués
dans les Grisons toujours en Suisse
tandis qu'hier 14 kurs étaient pris dans
une avalanche à zermat et ils ont
échappé à la mort absolument par miracle
en France hélas vous le savez la mort
blanche a de nouveau frappé hier à
lance- levillard près de Modane en
Morienne nos envoyés spéciaux de la
station de grenob sont sur place ils
font maintenant le point sur la
situation à lance- l
Villard à quelques à quelques kilomètres
au nord de Villard de lance un petit
bourg celui de lance levillard est venu
s'ajouter hier à la trop grande liste
des villages
evelis SEP morts et quatre blessés c'est
le bilan de cette nouvelle catastrophe
l'avalanche s déclenchée vers 16h45 hier
à très haute altitude la masse neigeuse
est descendue sur un front de 700 m tout
le secteur a été détruit ou gravement
endommagé soit SEP chalet et deux
hôtels malgré les secours arrivés
rapidement il semble qu'il y ait
toujours des corps ensevelis sous la
neige le nombre des disparu reste encore
imprécis un homme et une femme ont été
retirés ce matin des décombres de
l'hôtel du Grand sign ils pourront être
sauvés mais peu d'espoir pour les autres
ensevelis la valanche semblait
imprévisible à cet endroit alors que
l'autre extrémité du village et laissé
déserte les avalanches y étant
relativement fréquentes un témoignage
vous allez voir celui d'un moniteur de
lance levillard il était présent au
moment de la catastrophe et il a vu
arriver
[Musique]
l'avalanche vous avez vu de toute façon
que c'était tombé sur lance le bourg oui
ça lance le bourg vous êtes porté
immédiatement avec les les premiers
secours bien entendu oui bien sûr on est
arrivé très très très rapidement enfin
il y a quand même pas beaucoup de
mortsin comme on le prétend jusqu'à
présent on en a sorti combien à peu
près il y a eu 4 ou 5 pas plus hein il y
a eu le couple qui était juste devant
l'hôtel qui est derrière nous
actuellement il y a le jeune homme que
l'on est en train de sortir un couple de
vieillard qui se trouve en amont de
l'hôtel oui ça fait 5 ou si à peu près
he ça fait 5 ou 6 et est-ce qu'on pense
qu'il y en a encore à l'intérieur
puisque vous étiez sur les lieux il y a
il y a quelques minutes à peine ben à
l'intérieur on ne peut pas dire on ne
sait pas exactement et vous avez vu
l'état des lieux à l'intérieur comment
c'est l'état des lieux oui ça ve dire
qu'il y a les fenêtres qui sont
défoncées complètement alors c'est c'est
par là que la neige est rentrée c'est
c'est là où la neige a fait le plus de
mal il y non seulement de débris bien
sûr oui bien sûr il y a les débris de de
branches d'arbres qui étaient dans la
colline en face est-ce que est-ce que
vous aviez déjà eu connaissance d'une
d'une avalanche pareille ici àance
jamais jamais c'est impensable c'est
impensable jamais vu
ça d'une vallée à l'autre à valdiser et
à tigne on respire à nouveau puisque la
nationale 202 qui relie valdizer à Ting
a été dégagé ce matin vers 8h et puisque
le téléphone fonctionne à nouveau
avalanche et neige en altitude pluie et
cru dans les vallées février est
habituellement un mois difficile et
février 70 n'a pas failli à la
tradition tout le bassin de la seène est
en cru hier après-midi Jean Vila a
survolé ce bassin à bord d'un
hélicoptère de la gendarmerie voici ce
qu'il a vu et ses images donnent leur
véritable dimension à ces
[Musique]
inondations partout o la Scine a quitté
son lit et s répandu à travers les
champs et les villages les cru de Lyonne
et du loin ont encore aggravé la
situation
une dizaine de routes départementales
sont maintenant coupées à montre la
scène a atteint 3 M40 la code d'alerte
est dépassée la nationale 375 est coupée
amoré sur loin code d'alerte également
dépassé par le loin qui a envahi le
rez-de-chaussée d'un certain nombre de
maisons
riverenes situation grave également à
corbeon où la scène a atteint le niveau
de 4 4 m dépassant de 40 cm la côte
d'alerte de nombreuses stations de
pompage ont été installées notamment à
juvisi et à corbeille les services de la
protection civile de lesesson
surveillent attentivement le niveau du
fleuve plusieurs maisons ont été
inondées dans ce secteur ainsi qu'à
villeeneuve Leroi et dans le Val de
Marne à abblon la scne a atteint 5 M60
dépassant là encore sa côte d'alerte et
là aussi le service de protection civile
du valde Marne surveille la crue à Paris
même la scène devrait se maintenir à 5
M10 avant de recommencer à monter pour
atteindre 5 M40 demain et samedi et
peut-être même 6 m la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine depuis 8 jours déjà plusieurs
affluents de la Loire sont en cru et en
mains endroit leurs eau se sont répandu
sur les cultures et les prêves c'est le
cas du Loire qui a envahi les terrains
de camping de la chartre et de Château
du Loire mais les crues les plus
importantes ont eu lieu dans la vallée
de l'Indre et de la Loire on prévoit que
cette dernière atteindra 5 M90 à montgel
le 1er mars et la région de Rochefort
est entièrement recouverte par les eaux
une dizaine de maisons sont
isolées des routes en bordure du Cher
qui a atteint ce matin 3 M46 ont dû être
coupés à la circulation et la Vienne a
dépassé largement sa côte d'alerte puis
puisque son niveau approche les 5 m à
alançon au Man et à l'val les eaux de la
Sarte sont à leur niveau maximum des
rivières moins importantes sont
également en cru puisque la brême la six
et l'uine ont largement
débordé stabilisation ou très légère
descru telle est la situation en Alsace
sur le fond des inondations c'est le cas
notamment dans les régions de Strasbourg
et de Colmar plusieurs routes restent
cependant interdite à la circulation
notamment dans le sud de la région où la
situation demeure préoccupante
elle était hier au point de mettre en
alerte toutes les communes riverenes
Duin l'aide de l'armée avait été prévue
ce matin dans le cas d'une nette
aggravation à Mulous où l'on s'attend
même à une légère hausse de l'île et de
la dolaire l'usine AMCO baigne encore
dans 40 cm d'eau par ailleurs de
nombreuses caves sont encore
inondées la navigation Renan dont on
annoncé une reprise éventuelle ce matin
est toujours interrompue et il ne semble
pas qu'elle reprenne aujourd'hui puisque
le rein indique encore 5 M24 à
Strasbourg le niveau maximum a été
atteint hier
matin ainsi malgré la décru quasi
générale la situation en Alsace peut
redevenir critique si les pluies qui
s'abattent aujourd'hui en abondance sur
la région ne s'atténuent
pas et bien tandis qu'au nord de la
France on est inquiet et on est in
je dois dire que paradoxalement dans le
Midi l'eau fait défaut et le mistral
caractéristique du mauvais temps dans
cette région favorise les incendies de
forêt et on a tremblé hier à Nice où
trois incendies ont ravagé plusieurs
hectares de Maqui et de pined situé
autour de la ville on est inquiet
également dans l'Ouest car la mer en
cette saison est aussi cruelle que la
montagne à dieep on est sans nouvelle du
Jeane gougi un chalutier de 34 m
actuellement introuvable sa dernière
position connue le large de la côte
anglaise de cornoil il y avait 13 hommes
à bord nouvelle de l'étranger Extrême
Orient la situation est très critique au
la Haos pays voisin du Vietnam
l'offensive des forces communistes ne
s'est pas relâché depuis la prise de la
très importante plain d'jar depuis 10
jour les bombardiers américains B52
effectuent des raides quotidiens sur
cette région tandis que les forces
laoiennes reculent lentement
officialisant l'offensive et commentant
la victoire communiste le général diap
ministre nord-vietnamien de la défense
encourage ses frères làossiens à
combattre et à défaire les États-Unis et
les à les contraindre à une défaite
honteuse à Bangkok en Thaïlande pays
voisin du Laos on est inquiet toutes les
unités stationnant le long de la
frontière laosienne sont en état
d'alerte tandis qu'à vienstian capitale
du Laos on parle déjà d'un cessfeu suivi
de négociations entre les différentes
tendances laosiennes qui aujourd'hui
s'affrontent sur le terrain les
proommunistes soutenus par le
nordvietnam l'emportant pour l'instant
sur les gouvernementaux conseillés par
les Américains Moyen-Orient à New York
que Monsieur tante a regagné d'urgence
en raison de la situation au
Moyen-Orient le président de la
Fédération internationale des pilotes
civils le capitaine Forsberg est
profondément déçu par la démarche qu'il
vient d'entreprendre aux Nations Unies
désireux de porter le problème de la
sécurité des transports aériens face aux
attentats sur le bureau du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU il a renoncé à son
projet la difficulté est que cela ne
servirait à rien a dit Monsieur Forsberg
quelle que soit la personne convoquant
cette réunion pendant ce temps et
consécutivement à l'attentat dont fut
victime un appareil de la suissire à
Washington on annonce que le
gouvernement ne demandera pas aux
compagnies américaines d'interrompre
leur vol vers Israël le gouvernement
américain préfère intensifier les
mesures de sécurité à la suspension des
vols de même à Londres où plusieurs vols
à destination du Moyen-Orient ont été
retardés pour permettre des fouilles au
rayon X à ce propos on signale que le
boycott des employés de la BEAC à
l'égard des avions de H compagnies
aériennes arabes ont cessé
aujourd'hui mesures de sécurité
également en Italie à Rome où l'on
utilise un appareil capable de détecter
des explosifs et à Athènes on a arrêté
pour 48 he tout fret aérien à
destination d'Israël de leur côté les
responsables des compagnies aériennes
arabes vont se réunir prochainement afin
d'étudier quelle sera leur attitude et
qu'el sera les quelles seront les
répercussions de l'attentat de zurik sur
le trafic aérien vers le Moyen-Orient
Moyen-Orient toujours mais sur place
cette fois Jacques abouchard notre
envoyé spécial en Jordanie nous relate
les conversations qui se sont déroulées
samedi et dimanche entre le leader
palestinien et le roi
Hussein donc il y a accord entre le roi
et les organisations de résistance
palestinienne accord tout théorique
disent certains en fait les fedaïnes ont
dicté leurs conditions au roi Hussein
ils ont manifesté leur bonne volonté en
s'imposant eux-mêmes parce qu'ils ont
bien voulu quelques restrictions mais il
n'empêche que lorsqu'on se promène dans
les rues d'Aman de nouveau les féïes en
armes sont partout et puis certains ici
les plus pessimistes pensent que de
toute façon l'affrontement aura lieu la
trêve actuelle dis-il ne se prolongera
pas c'est peut-être l'affaire de
quelques semaines en effet si Arafat
bien coexister avec la monarchie dans
son intérêt propre et il vient de le
confirmer au cours de sa conférence de
presse si donc Arafat est d'accord pour
le statuo il a des alliés remant qui eux
voudrai bien affronter les Bédouins la
garde royale du roi Hussein parmi ces
alliés figure le docteur George abach
c'est le leader de l'organisation FPLP
le Front Populaire de Libération de la
Palestine souvenez-vous c'est cette
organisation qui la première avait
entamé les attaques contre les les
aéroports et les détournements d'avion
et le docteur George abach a dit à
plusieurs reprises que il n'hésiterait
pas à prendre le pouvoir si l'occasion
lui en a été
donnée vous verrez ce soir au cours de
notre édition de 19h45 une interview
exclusive que Monsieur George abach a
accordé à notre enveiller spécial
Jacques aboucha une dépêche que que l'on
m'apporte à l'instant concernant les
avalanches qui menacent à nouveau lance
le Villard font état d'un bil an
officiel qui serait de H morts deux
disparus et h blessés nouvelle de
l'Europe au communes hier à Londres
s'est ouvert un long débat sur la
candidature britannique au Marché Commun
monsieur George Thomson ministre
britannique chargé des questions
européennes a précisé que son pays
n'entendait pas joindre les 6 au
détriment de sa communauté propre
c'est-à-dire le Commonwealth mais a-t-il
déclaré il s'agit de parier sur les
conditions de vie du peuple britannique
de l'an 2000 nos enfants ne nous
pardonneront pas facilement si le
Parlement a pris la mauvaise décision
hier s'est achevé à Paris la réunion des
ministres des Finances des 6 et bien que
la France préconise une coopération
monétaire et que l'Allemagne de son côté
préfère donner la priorité à une
harmonisation économique l'Europe
communautaire
s'organise l'union monétaire se fera
sans doute en 1980 en 3 qu ou 7 étapes à
ce propos gules a rencontré hier soir
notre ministre des
Finances monsieur le ministre est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment qu'on a progressé
dans la voie d'une unité monétaire
européenne aujourd'hui je crois que nous
avons pris un bon départ nous avons
consacré l'après-midi d'hier la journée
d'aujourd'hui à réfléchir entre les
ministres des Finances des 6 et les
gouverneurs des banques centrales au
problèm de l'organisation monétaire de
l'Europe nous avions devant nous des
projets un projet allemand un projet
belge un projet luxembourgeois et en
même temps des propositions qui nous
étaient faites par la Commission de
Bruxelles et nous avons réfléchi à tous
ces problèmes ensemble et j'ai
l'impression que sur l'objectif final
nous sommes en réalité d'accord les uns
avec les les autres et donc
effectivement l'organisation monétaire
de l'Europe a pris un bon départ nous
aurons donc un jour une monnaie
européenne est-ce qu'on peut avoir une
idée du calendrier ça serait pour quand
par non je crois qu'il est prématuré à
l'heure actuelle de fixer une date
encore que dans les programmes qui nous
seront soumis notamment par la
Commission de Bruxelles il y aura je
crois un calendrier fixant les étapes
successives et leur date à l'heure
actuelle ce que nous avons ce dont nous
avons convenu c'était de faire des
propositions sur la procédure c'est la
manière de préparer cette organisation
monétaire nous avons prévu qu'on
déciderait la constitution d'un comité
qui devrait faire des propositions d'ici
3 mois afin que le Conseil des ministres
des 6 puisse avant l'été prochain se
mettre d'accord précisément sur les
étapes de cette organisation monétaire
vous voyez que avant l'été prochain nous
aurons les uns et les autres et
l'opinion publique avec nous
connaissance de la manière et du
calendrier avec laquelle l'Europe sera
organisé du point de vue de sa monnaie
cette monnaie il faudra la baptiser un
jour est-ce qu'on lui a cherché un nom
déjà non on n pas cherché un nom nous
pouvons avoir des idées personnelles
j'en ai à proposer le moment venu mais
ça n'est pas la peine de baptiser un
enfant avant qu'il soit né d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas comme ça que ça se produit
assistons à la naissance nous ferons le
bapthème ensuite bien et bien nous
quittons le domaine de la politique pour
parler sport maintenant avec Jean-Michel
leelio nous parlons d'un combat de boxe
oule
oui Jean-Paul Daniel vermander champion
de France des poisplumes il est ici à
gauche de votre écran à conservé son
bien hier au cirque d'hiveréx le
challenger n'a pu pendant 15 reprises
forcer la décision bermander évitant les
corps à corps tenant son adversaire à
distance grâce à une allonge
supérieure mais pourtant ce ne fut pas
un championnat de haut niveau il
illustre assez bien la pauvreté
d'effectif de valeur chez certaines
catégorie du noblard thmander qui fut
bon amateur avant de de rallier le
professionnalisme n'avait jamais boxé en
15 round c'est pourtant lui qui se
montrait le plus actif au cours des
ultimes
reprises
malheureusement Brami se servait un peu
trop d'une arme interdite les coups de
tête bilan arcade souciliaire du
champion de France ouverte à la 7e
reprise arcade gauche à la 12e reprise
et un avertissement de l'arbitre pour
sanctionner avec juste raison la façon
de boxer de Bram finalement l'arbitre
allait arrêter le combat au 13e round en
disqualifiant
Bram et après cette juste décision je
dit bien juste décision certains
spectateurs toujours les mêmes
d'ailleurs que ce soit au Palais des
sports au Cirque d'Hiver provoquèrent un
début d'émeut suivi d'une mise à sac de
la salle les voyou fréquentent
décidément avec beaucoup trop d'acidité
les salles de boxe Brami ici après le
combat des su Vermand les deux arcades
ouvertes et un certain public que l'on
n'aimerait pas voir trop
souvent
[Musique]
et bien après la politique le sport nous
parlons chiffon avec Jacqueline
Alexandre oui des chiffons de valeur par
leur rareté en effet savez-vous qu'en
France nous sommes le seul pays au monde
à posséder un centre de documentation du
costume il vient d'ouvrir ses portes
boulevard malzerb voici un reportage m
en image par Jean-François Renou
le centre de documentation du costume
est la première étape vers la création
d'un musée français du costume
mademoiselle Yvon deslandre ancien élève
de l'École des chartes en est la
responsable nous lui avons demandé
comment et pourquoi ce centre avait été
créé et surtout pour
qui je vois venir ici des gens de toutes
les sortes le costume touche à tout
l'être humain car ce n'est pas notre
corps que nous habillons c'est notre
esprit par conséquent toute personne qui
s'intéresse à l'être humain devrait
venir me voir j'estime que tous les
historiens devraient passer leur vie ici
déjà tous les professionnels du costume
aussi bien dans le monde du spectacle
que dans le monde de la création que
dans le monde du préortter que dans le
monde de la création textile vienne chez
moi madame vous faites une étude sur le
prête àortter depuis sa création que
recherchez-vous ici j'ai choisi le prê à
porter féminin et j'ai trouvé les
premiers catalogues de prêt à porter qui
sont parus vers 1850 et qui sont du
magasin du Louvre où il y a toute la
mode à crinoline je suis laaché de press
d'un grand couturier Pierre Balmain la
dernière conférence qu'il avait faite
était intitulé rapport entre costume et
civilisation et j'ai trouvé des
documents absolument complets et fort
bien coordonnés je suis costumire de
théâtre c'est vous-même qui réalisez les
modèles oui que venez-vous chercher ici
bien c'estàd que on est appelé à avoir
bien sûr des costumes d'une certaine
époque et on a des patrons qui sont tout
faits ici que l'on vient voir parce que
c'est beaucoup plus simple pour nous
d'avoir carrément une base qui soit
vraie et on n pas à tâonner ou à
chercher des formes des volumes qui
seront forcément faux puisque on n plus
les mêmes façons de voir que aux époques
où c'était fait nous avions besoin de
patron de corsé de patrons de jupon la
façon dont les robes les dos vatau
étaient fait les plis là au 17 17e 18e
siècle on a beaucoup plus de documents
c'est beaucoup plus facile comment
avez-vous obtenu toute cette
documentation dont nous voyons une
partie ici dans cette bibliothèque nous
l'avons obtenu à peu près uniquement par
des dons soit les dons des maisons de
couture qui nous ont remis leur
documentation ça a été le cas de Madame
Vionet qui a été une des grandes
couturières entre 1920 et 1940 une des
plus grandes maisons de Paris et qui
nous a remis toute sa documentation
aussi bien photographie que patron que
robe puisque nous avons actuellement à
peu près 200 robes de Madeleine vionnaet
c'est une richesse que les musées
américain nous envit beaucoup des
échantillons de textille la plus
importante collection étant celle de la
maison Rodier et tout récemment encore
il y a 8 jours très exactement madame
scaparelli a eu l'extrême obligeance de
nous remettre toute sa documentation à
peu près 6000 dessins en dehors de toute
cette documentation vous avez également
d'innombrables costumes d'époque comment
les avez-vous réuni de la même manière
en les recevant pard vous n'achetez rien
ah si quelquefois mais seulement quand
vraiment le propriétaire est tout à fait
récalcitrant on essaie toujours de le
persuader de donner tenez c'est le cas
de cette admirable veste qui est un don
tout récent c'est une broderie de la
maison rbé pour Christian lor et la dame
du reste fort généreuse qui me donnait
une trentaine de vêtements ayant
appartenu à sa mère n'avait pas envie de
me donner ce costume c'est à peu près
que est plus beau comme banderie
moderne comment les donateurs ont eu
idée de vous apporter leurs costumes
mais ils en ont l'idée parce que nous
faisons tout de même assez souvent des
manifestations nous prêtons nos costumes
à des expositions et les gens qui les
voient ont l'idée de nous proposer des
dons il y a nos amis nos amis
particuliers très nombreux il y a aussi
les professionnels les maisons de
couture les maisons de prê apporter qui
nous donnent les vêtements au fur et à
mesure de leur fabrication si je puis
dire car je ne compte pas beaucoup sur
les greniers de l'avenir pour y
retrouver des tailleurs pantalons je ne
pense pas qu'on les aura gardé dans 100
temps c'est pourquoi je me donne
beaucoup de mal pour solliciter les
maisons les plus importante qui marque
le plus l'évolution du goût à l'heure
actuelle de me donner l'UR vêtement leur
modèle les plus caractéristiques afin
que nous en gardions le souvenir l'idéal
pour moi serait qu'on me donne le
vêtement le plus vendu dans l'année et
de temps en temps un chef-dœuvre pour
éviter la monotonie quel sont vos pires
ennemis les balles costumé car toute
jeune fille qui dispose dans son grenier
d'une Europe de sa grand-mère s'imagine
qu'elle sera ravissante avec c'est une
erreur dans les trois/4s des cas et de
plus le corsage éclate alors on fait un
coussin avec la jupe et la robe n'arrive
pas et c'est pourquoi nous avons tant de
mal à recueillir à temps des objets dont
les propriétaires ne soupçonnent pas
l'intérêt ni l'importance les gens ne
connaissent pas leur fortune fortune non
ça se vend très mal il n'y a qu'une
chose qui est un prix marqué ce sont les
robes du 18e siècle et que les
antiquires qui sont mes grands rivaux à
cet égard pour recouvrir des meubles
pour moi ça a fait disparaître déjà un
très grand nombre de robes que j'ai vu
c'est ça nos vrais ennemis le centre de
documentation du costume aimerait
beaucoup vous compter au nombre de ses
amis la Bourse de Paris maintenant avec
Gérard
vidalange marché très calme aujourd'hui
à la Bourse de Paris pas de nouvelles
décisives il y a tout de même bien sûr
beaucoup de curieux qui accompagnent les
professionnels et il à l'instant un club
féminin du reste qui se renseignait sur
le fonctionnement du marché il y a eu
tout de même un mouvement en ce qui
concerne les mines d'or et les grandes
sociétés financières sud-africaines ces
valeurs ont légèrement monté aujourd'hui
sans doute parce que l'on constate que
les rendements offerts par ces titres
sont assez substantiels des rendements
qui sont souvent supérieurs à 10
% voici par exemple le cours de la
debirs 41 francs mais des minor aut que
la westre fontaine sont en hausse
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne les
valeurs françaises il y a des hausses
par exemple sur schneedre sur Alstom sur
la Compagnie générale d'électricité
c'est donc plutôt la les grandes
affaires de la construction électrique
qui sont surveillé actuellement alors
que les grandes valeurs chimiques
maintiennent simplement leur position et
les valeurs de magasin et de la
sidérurgie également se born à répéter
leur cours de la veille en ce qui
concerne la construction électrique le
président Pompidou aux États-Unis a été
amené à évoquer l'affaire Gemon schnedre
dans sa conférence de presse devant les
journalistes américains et il a rappelé
merci Gérard vidalangeche nos prochaines
informations à 18h50 mesdames etes
messieurs bonne
[Musique]
journée